do you think that maybe maybe that if
more people had known about Hunter
Biden's laptop and Hunter Biden's
business dealings that clearly were
connected to Joe Biden Hunter Biden was
a crack addict who had no expertise in
energy who was getting all this money
per month from a Ukrainian Energy
company do you think that is sort of
relevant to what's going on in Ukraine
now do you think that's sort of relevant
to Joe Biden becoming president but they
couldn't talk about it then and then of
course my favorite slow-motion
conservative Bill Maher even he gets
these things right usually two years
late the argument to me is like has
Twitter failed in setting themselves up
in the past as the judge of what can go
out there and I would say yes you have
you failed
when you threw the New York Post off of
Twitter
for talking about Hunter Biden's emails
it turned out that was a real story
right you failed when you said we
couldn't read about whether covet had
come from a lab
you failed
did you read about this Babylon bead you
know what the Babylon bee is I didn't
know this no it's like the Christian
version of The Onion they got flagged
for they posted a funny video this is
funny to them okay
sensitive content Twitter said in the
video they were making fun of Twitter
for being too sensitive this is so
through the Looking Glass
okay so you guys know and by the way I
know that if some of you uh are are
annoyed when I keep playing these
billmar clips because you're like you
kind of want to smack me through the
screen I can feel it like Dave he's
never gonna fully get there he's never
gonna fully get there but I'm going to
keep trying at least a little bit more
because I think that that slow motion
thing that he's doing needs to be
accelerated and I think maybe we can get
the rubber to meet the road with him
maybe we can maybe I'm completely wrong
but I think maybe we can and even if we
can't get him maybe we can get more of
his audience to realize what the truth
is right because hopefully if the
algorithms don't manipulate everything
there might be a person out there who
searches Bill Maher on the YouTube and
comes across one of my videos and is
like oh this guy actually nailed what
what's been going on in the back of my
head when I watch Real Time why it's not
fully connecting what's interesting
there is Bill Maher finally is coming
around right he's coming around and
going they did fail when it came to this
New York Post story now it's interesting
Bill Maher didn't cover the New York
Post story on his show when it was
happening now a whole bunch of us did
and we were called right-wing Maniacs
for it we were told we were going to be
censored on YouTube and many of us were
but he didn't do it when it mattered
that's what I mean about slow motion
Conservative then when it gets easy to
do something when the New York Times is
like oh yo you're not going to believe
this guys but it's a year and a half
later and Biden already president so uh
yeah you can talk about the laptop then
Bill Maher is like yeah why did we talk
about laptop okay so he says that uh he
also to the idea that you're going to
say okay well Twitter should have done
something and not you know basically
should have not done anything I should
say they should have not banned the New
York Post and everything else it's like
well you know they probably shouldn't
have ban the president of the United
States where were you on that bill
yeah nowhere on that one too you did
call for a recession though to get rid
of trump uh so again this is like are
you getting this or not uh and then oh
and then the lab leak he mentions the
lab leak and it's like yeah Bill where
were you on the lab league for a year
you you were afraid to talk about it too
for a year I don't know if the lab leak
is true or not but at least we were some
of us were asking these questions
so just come on Bill
and I know the producers watch this show
I have my insiders I know you're
watching just get there bill I don't
even want to do the [ __ ] show I
really don't I don't even I'm not even
that interested in talking to him
anymore I'm honestly not but just get
there man get there send me a nice
bottle of wine at the end that would be
my bottle of tequila would be better
actually but the point of all of this is
that the election was manipulated by big
Tech so it is not disconnected when you
see public people having their accounts
blown up Jordan Peterson or me being
suspended when you just follow those
dots backwards and you go boy they were
censoring other things back then and
gosh darn it did those things have an
effect on the election and it's yes yes
that they did so you guys know I like to
go back to some things that happened in
the past so we don't forget right
because we just forget things that
happen literally two weeks ago